no no not i'm not a rap that's an inside
joke
1927. let's go back to the accelerated
dragon
and he plays the smith mora now i'm not
going to take the pawn
and this plays back into the psychology
of gambit players
when you resist their kind of territory
uh they get frustrated so what can black
do here
uh by way of refusing the smith moore
what is the best way to refuse it droopy
miller thank you for three months
we can transpose them to the aleppo and
sicilian we can transpose into the
aleppo and sicilian by playing knight f6
i'll explain this
in greater depth after the game so we've
trans literally transposed into the
elephant which is also annoying
uh which i've played queen takes d4 is
the way that most smith moral players
actually go here so
uh this i actually know very well um
well i know not very well i know it
decently so you go e6 to defend the
knight
uh queen takes d4 is a very dangerous
line if black doesn't know what to do
uh of course i would refer you to mark
esterman's amazing book mayhem in the
mora
and i don't say amazing about a lot of
books so it's a labor of love
uh mark is the ultimate specialist in
the mora you should listen to him rather
than me but as far as i know
uh the move here is f5 we chase the
queen away
and now this is the key let me remember
so let me actually try to remember my
analysis yes
so here's the thing white wants to play
c4
we go b5 here we sacrifice the pawn in
order to get queen side counter play
this is still theory
and um he doesn't take the pawn and now
i think we go either
a5 or we can develop the bishop first
so let's go a5 continuing to expand
and then bishop a6 basically creating
that potential skewer against the queen
knight to a4
now this one i already don't know maybe
i'm still caught in theory
let me think about this so he wants
queen h5 he wants queen h5
and uh that's got kind of concerning and
he also wants to take on d5 can we
defend against both threats at the same
time
well we can drop the knight back to e7
not glamorous but
i guess i messed up here i don't know uh
this guy this guy out prepared me
so um we'll see but that's not the end
of the world now we can get our queen to
c7
in order to pressure the pawn on e5
all right relax focus grassy we will we
will see
plenty of 1900s know this much theory uh
particularly if um
okay so rookie one now uh there's a
couple of problems here that we need to
solve here uh the first is the problem
with this bishop right this bishop is
not about but if we go g6 we create
holes in our position um that that he
can potentially occupy but again it's
all about the priorities
our top priority here is to complete our
development come on may buy hooker by
crook
we're gonna fianchetto the bishop and
then we're gonna try to castle so that i
don't get checkmated in the center of
the board
miss skewer on b4 nope i actually saw
that um
i did see the move before and he has c4
in response to that
so i did actually spot that move
but i don't believe it was that good
okay so he goes
b4 that is a very odd move i i mean
i'm not gonna really react to it i'm
just gonna complete my development
okay so bishop to b2
um now let's unpack this for a second
i'm not sure why i can't just take on e5
uh but i'm actually gonna trust him and
i'm gonna castle here i'm a little bit
concerned that this is still like
semi-preparation so i'm just gonna
complete my development i think he had
some ideas like c4
okay but now i'm not going to trust him
any longer what should black do here
i mean and let's keep it simple i think
that we can now just do what
yeah we can just take the pawn you just
take and take and i actually um
i actually don't see what he has in
return for this
okay and uh we're up upon
we still have this very nice outpost for
the knight
now this bishop on a6 is sort of dull
right but it's got a lot of potential
energy
especially if we play the move b4 so
uh what should we do here how do we
prepare the move b4
well there's a couple things to notice
here he's attacking the pawn on d5 on b5
he's sort of semi-attacking because if
he takes it he walks himself into a very
nasty little pin
uh but actually i think he can get away
with this and i'll explain this after
the game
so huh this is a complicated situation
what i'm gonna do
let me think about this i'm going to go
queen to a5 the idea is simple
i just want to defend the pawn first and
then i want to go knight b to d5 i think
that this queen
is actually going to be very well placed
here it's going to put pressure on the
pawn
which is going to discourage him from
bringing his rook into the game
yeah i could have moved the other night
but then this knight would have gotten
uncomfortable
okay now we're going to go knight b to
d5 according to planet h4 is a good move
uh he's he's starting to pressure and
massage my king side which is kind of
weak
so it's time for me to act okay so take
stakes
and now we're gonna go before opening up
the bishop it's a battle on both flanks
queen to d2 though very strong move here
um and uh my king side is in some
trouble here so i'm gonna have to be
very careful about it
okay he does it so
let's just take this pawn let's just get
rid of it uh
and it does ruin my king side a little
bit that is true
but here's the thing uh he doesn't have
any pieces on the king side yet so it's
not like
checkmate is imminent uh he can put his
queen on g5 but
yup he does uh and but but but i can
bring my defenders in as well
and i want to emphasize that you
shouldn't be afraid of moves like these
just because they look intimidating
because now i've brought my own queen
into the game
my queen's gonna have something to say
about the threat of knight g5
okay so he should definitely not trade
queens he's playing
very well but i think we'll be able to
survive this
okay yeah his pawn on e5 is really
working in my favor we again have the
same situation
three pieces biting on the same pawn
which is very much to my favor
okay what should we do here to complete
the defensive operation
what should we do to complete the
defensive operation
we have we aren't done on the king's
side we need to
get the queen to g6 we need to get the
queen to g6
so that knight g5 is is is no longer
dangerous because it will not
attack h7 okay
so rook c1 i'm going to respond to with
rook to c8 i'm not going to let him
run circles over me get control of the c
file also c3 square something we should
keep in mind uh for the future potential
outpost
okay and this guy is just good but uh
he's legit
so a couple of options here he wants to
take on d5 and ruin our structure that
it would not be acceptable thing to
allow so what should we do
what are the options here we could
consider f4 that's actually a super
interesting move
uh but but i don't really want to allow
bishop takes d5 so
bishop b7 allows his knight to get
around to d6 so let's actually go knight
to c3 let's use that outpost that we
created on the previous move
and f4 by the way ripping open the king
yeah he made a very strong move here
which i sort of
semi underestimated um let me think
for a second thank you godless for the
tier one
hmm
yeah that's a very nasty move
very very nasty move and 92 is possible
but then my knight gets passive let's
tickle him actually
let's go bishop h6 uh let's bring the
bishop into the game
and tickle his rook i think bishop h6 is
actually a very strong move
uh and it's a very important move
because otherwise my knight was getting
undermined
very complex game and i love this i'll
be able to talk through a lot of
concepts after the game
but in the interest of time i have to
make some moves fast
okay now we can bring the other bishop
where is the rook going this is the
power of having active pieces as goblins
with a five gifted keeps the hype going
amazing
his rook's not going anywhere all of our
pieces guarding the rook's potential
escape squares
okay so he takes on c3 now we don't want
to rush to take the rook
we can just play b take c3 and uh
he's stuck between a rock and a hard
place because if he moves the rook then
he allows our pawn to push forward
and he's gonna have to give up a piece
for it which is exactly what's gonna
happen he has to give up the knight for
it
and now we are officially winning we are
up a full piece and
we still have the potential to rip up in
the king's side
guys uh please keep the unfounded
accusations on the basis of two moves to
a minimum
um that's not what we're about here
uh trust me if somebody actually is
cheating i usually have a good sense of
it
and i will make that known but uh i in
you know put yourself in the shoes and i
don't mean to lecture anybody here
uh we've all gotten paranoid but put
yourself in this guy's shoes if you're
playing a good game would you like
uh you know would you like for an entire
community to turn against to turn
against you because you happen to know
the theory
so just common sense justice will be
served
okay uh so let's lift the rook up to h5
uh you know so
okay now we're gonna lift the rook up
and this is just gonna be checkmate to
the queen and the game is over
okay so that's winning
um now all right that was a nice move
um so uh smith moore
now d-tank c3 is the accepted smith mora
again i would defer to mark's analysis
here in his book
um knight f6
so the accuracy i know people are
curious uh so the accuracy was
probably not too high from my end let's
see
it's analyzing it just one second jayrud
thank you so much
appreciate it
okay so his accuracy was
it was 61 okay so
he made a lot of mistakes 88.7 for me uh
he played a very nice game let's not
take anything away from him
uh but you know if you make up your mind
after three moves
then uh you're not giving the guy a
chance thank you thank you tcrh for the
300 appreciate the message
so i think that my mistake
was the move bishop a6 i think i forgot
to play bishop e7
and the purpose behind bishop e7 is to
stop the knight from getting to h4
uh and and that's the key move that i
missed then you play bishop basics i
confuse the move order
and very nicely done by him knight h4 uh
opening up the possibility for quinn h5
so i had to drop my knight back i had to
double it back
for completed here he started going
wrong with b4
um thanks shark appreciate it um here he
started going wrong with before i think
he should have gone here
and maybe you know chiseled his way into
my position here with bishop f6
um and uh that's sort of how i think he
should have nurtured the initiative
uh well you know i've gotten accused
myself and i understand uh that
you know definitely people have accused
me of cheating and uh
fresh freeze and i understand it's a
human instinct
to get frustrated when somebody's
playing well cheating is a huge problem
i'm the first person to say that
uh but we have to be equitable as much
as possible because
we don't want to throw the baby out with
the bath water there
uh crow kaka thank you for the prime and
fresh trees as well
okay um
so and i uh i've shared a funny story
before about getting accused i was
playing an unnamed grandmaster
on icc this was years ago and i had a
secret account on icc
so i played a cheater and i think i drew
him because
it flagged him but uh then i noticed
that that grandmaster was also playing
uh the cheater and i messaged him i was
like you're playing a clear cheater
oh no i said this guy is a cheater and
he said just like you
i was like dang girl i'm making his
opinions no so i get it
but let's move on so anyways we cancel
we complete our development went upon
now here's the thing knight b to d5 is
what people
uh is is what uh people were sort of
wanting me to do but he takes on b5
and here's the key thing it seems like
we're winning the knight on b5 but we're
not
how can he defend that knight how can he
defend that knight
yeah this is an authorized speed run
account jesse rogers so every
people are aware a4 is the move exactly
pawns are very good defenders
it's an anchor so remember the key
principle when you can
do something with a pawn you usually
should versus doing it with a piece
okay so before opening up the diagonal
taking the pawn and then getting the
queen into the defense okay
these are the moves that won me the game
queen d a queen e8 these are the moves
that a lot of people
uh would be unwilling to play i think
because they're retreating moves it
looks like we've done something
wrong uh but the priority here is to get
is to beef up our king side security
uh contesting the c file now knight c3
was a little hasty but bishop h6 here
how did i see this move
well i basically i tried to think
logically about what's making his
position
tick what's making his position tick are
three things right the pawn
which is undermining my pawn the bishop
and the rook
that's like a mechanism right you can
think of that in a vacuum
can we try to disrupt that mechanism in
some way
can we attack the bishop i consider this
move this would have been a very
reasonable move
but i was worried about putting my
knight on the rim can we win the pawn i
mean no because if we take the pawn we
dropped the knight
but the rook is a weak lick link and i
mentioned this before
usually the strongest piece is the
easiest piece to attack because it has
to respond
to most attacks and that's why i settled
on bishop h6
he could have shut me down with f4 but
that would have created a weakness on g3
then we can go knight a4
and he his queen is kind of tied down to
the pawn okay
so um yeah i know some people were
thinking that and this is just
winning yeah if four was possible
um what's up logic yeah yeah i know i
know
i've been yeah um
well i'm excited to hear what um
what what what this is that you
mentioned but uh anyways
we've got we've got as if all of the
hype wasn't enough we got the man
himself in the chat as well
um the absolute freaking man in the chat
himself
okay so um but basically yeah this is
just winning for black because the rook
is um
the rook is just completely trapped what
would you say the main takeaway is well
first of all um
theoretically speaking uh i'm not immune
to
screwing up in the opening okay i'm not
immune bloodline i thank you for the
tier one i'm not immune
uh to confusing stuff okay and and i did
that here so don't think that just
because you know i'm a gm or something i
know everything about the opening i do
stupid stuff all the time but i didn't
panic
and i prioritized the right things which
is completing the development then i
took the pawn
and and the main thing that won me the
game was recognizing when you need to
make these
unglamorous moves okay these unglamorous
moves are what
are the glue moves that win you the game
right and and if you can know when to
make them
uh you stop your opponent's threats and
uh you
you know you you end up in much better
shape
let me see doesn't bishop g someone
stated uh how to recognize well
if it was that simple uh everybody would
be a gm but i'm trying my best to uh
you know to flesh out the thought
process why didn't you take the rook
when it was trapped
well uh because basically
i again there's no rush if we take the
rook then he plays bishop takes b4
and at least he curbs his losses here
not only is he going to lose his rope
but if he moves it he loses
more stuff than that so this is just uh
i'm just going for more here than just
the exchange
but here we go no time wasted another
game let's hope thank you jay grindel
for the five gifted okay
so he plays the karo khan defense which
is we've encountered it a couple of
times
black prepares to go d5 now we know that
we want to control the center here
and he goes d6 he doesn't go d5 okay
so basically uh what am i going to do
now i'm simply going to develop my
pieces
which is um which is what you basically
do in the opening
my opponent is just pushing his pawns
out which is weird
uh it's weird but i don't have to change
my strategy because my opponent's doing
something weird
what should i do in this position how
should we continue developing
and what's sort of the best the simplest
way of developing our pieces we're going
to keep it simple here keep it old
school
who can tell me the simplest possible
move
we could play sorry we could play off
four to control the center
but what i'm going to do is simply go
knight f3 no knights before bishops is
the key role now i'm going to develop my
bishop
now i'm going to castle in the meantime
he's just trolling me he's pushing all
his pawns out
he thinks he's being intimidating or
funny neither of which are true okay
maybe he's being funny now
here's the thing he finally developed a
piece thank you mr x
when your opponent plays this passively
you guys already know
kind of the general thing that we have
to do
which is to open up the center because
by opening up the center
we're going to allow my pieces uh to
just to actually infiltrate otherwise
he's going to get away with this
so we need a plan now the obvious way of
opening the center is to go e5
but then he's gonna go d5 and keep
things shut so what should i do
how should i smash the center open and
keep it open
should i go e5 no i shouldn't what
should i do
let's get that hammer in and let's go d5
and i'm going to play a little bit
faster we had another plan
that would have been even better and
i'll explain it after the game but here
this is simple now he's trying to close
the center
look at this pawn on e5 very carefully
what i want to do here is i want to push
my pawn out to f4
in order to contest that pawn in order
to open up that e file which is the main
artery to his king
but i can't do that right because
there's a knight in the way where should
we put the knight
let's go knight d2 i didn't choose this
square at random this knight could then
travel to c4
and attack the b6 pawn okay he stops me
from going f4
now knight c4 immediately would be fine
but then he would push his pawn out to
b5 and attack my knight
um what should i do to preemptively stop
him
from pushing this pawn kind of like a
surgeon you know you're you're
handcuffing that pawn we should go a4
we use our pawn to prevent hispan from
moving on the next move we're going to
sandwich this knight on c4
and we've got a very nice position here
we haven't really fully opened up the
center
but his position is really full of holes
one of those holes
is f5 we're going to stick a bishop
there just keep on increasing the
pressure
and guess what well we've got this
e-file right we want to open up the file
but we can't do that yet we got to
prepare it let's prepare it by going
rookie one and we're actually kind of
ready to play f4 but
okay so he shuts down that e file um
let's continue
sort of chiseling our way uh into his
position how do we do that we can deploy
our queen but i want to go
a5 to create this little outpost for my
knight on b6 oh
that's not a good move by him what
should we take with the knight or the
rook
what do you guys think and again those
of you
who are sort of like not fully falling i
will explain everything after the game
in far more depth you can see this is a
five minute game so i have to play fast
some things i cannot explain at one of
the time too
we take with the knight why because we
attack the bishop we want to play
actively
we want to recapture in a way that
creates a threat also this knight has
access to an outpost
now we're going to lift our rook up
potentially aiming for c4 where it's
going to chase the queen away
remember rooks can be activated too but
we can't go rook c4 immediately right
why not
because we dropped the knight so can one
of you brave souls
tell me how can we first defend the
knight
so that we can then deploy our rook to
c4 yes
sir nose knows all does know the move
it's queen a1
what am i doing well that queen's going
to guard the knight oh and he's going to
regret this he
is going to regret this because we're
going to take it
now we're going to complete our plan now
we've given up a pawn but i've
sacrificed it i haven't blundered it
and the reason i sacrificed it is to
open up that center remember that that
was our initial plan
and our opponent has basically done that
for us that's what a sacrifice is in
chess
it's when you give something up for some
reason right you give up upon
in order to do something that's good for
you okay
now we're going to well what should we
do we've got a million moves here
let me think for a second i also have to
i think let's go knight c6
let's stick our knight on this outpost
queen to b7
now let's just keep increasing the
pressure how should we do that
can somebody propose a move how should
we keep increasing the pressure
let's go queen to a4 absolutely creating
a pin
now we can take with the rook very good
guys
all of you are sharp i appreciate it the
engagement okay
so now let's lift the other rook up to
b3 let's go
and where is mr queen going here now the
thing is
if the queen moves out to c7 ladies and
gentlemen thank you 107 bits
it it walks right into the x-ray of the
other rook this is what happens when you
have well-placed pieces
um mrs queen i just
sorry that was bad mrs queen of course
um but basically yeah he's on the ropes
now
if if knight b6 follows here
um then well then we have several things
that we can do
now notice that the queen is undefended
here so if i move the queen
let's say to here
then he will not be able to take the
rook uh because
uh because the queen will be undefended
but actually this is not so simple
he does have a move uh d5 which i didn't
fully anticipate
uh but okay so he's this guy is playing
very well so let me take
let me think for a second here we're
still in good shape don't worry
okay so he does this wow that is a very
strong move
yeah this is actually kind of sticky i
have to say
okay we can take the rook though
and now we can slide this rook over to
g3 now i've got a focus i've got 20
seconds
this might be the strongest opponent we
face today
so i couldn't have taken the knight and
i'll explain why after the game it was
an insane tactical idea that he came up
with
okay now we're going to undermine this
pawn and create some create some look
for our king
again i'll explain everything after the
game but you guys can see i have 23
seconds so i gotta play fast
the suspense is on
the charlie fans came at a great time
okay we're gonna take the pun he gives
us a check we're gonna move the king
now i do happen to like bullet chests so
this is you know i'm experienced in
these types of situations
and i gotta make a move my man my
goodness
okay
yeah this guy is vastly underrated
vastly underrated but i think we'll be
fine
all right drum roll please ladies and
gentlemen
drum roll please nobody go anywhere
i'm actually nervous i'm winning but
i've got 13 seconds will i make it
will i make it
11 seconds to win the end game will i do
it
all right where you got an endgame i'm
up a piece but i gotta win this in nine
seconds
i gotta start pre-moving
we're gonna make it happen ladies and
gentlemen we're gonna make it happen
i'm gonna win this that was close that
was the closest i've come to losing a
speedrun game this guy was incredible
but wait i still gotta win and i got
seven seconds to checkmate him
but the thing is at some point the
center is your muscle memory what i'm
doing here is i'm doing something called
a pre-move
a pre-move is a move that you execute
regardless
of what your opponent does it only takes
1.1 seconds to make a pre-move
so i'm able to to make a lot more moves
now here i have a queen against the king
this is
one of the easiest checkmates in chess
i'll be able to basically check my name
while pre-moving all of my moves
and what you can see that i'm doing here
is i'm cutting off his king
boom boom and ladies and gentlemen we
have
ourselves a checkmate what a game what a
game
and the perfect yeah there's so much to
talk about here
now the one thing i want to emphasize is
that it's not about playing games fast i
want to make sure i explain everything
so that people actually learn
you guys shouldn't be that impressed i
shouldn't have let this get down
this close um and you know
i i definitely let this slip a little
bit in some moment but he played very
well
so i i did my best okay so let's go
through this game
let me unpack everything for you guys so
basically
in the opening okay when you start a
chess game
basically you want to control the center
the center
broadly speaking is these four squares
that i just highlighted in red
when you control the center your pieces
get more space and you're able to put
your pieces on better squares
where they can be better positioned to
start an attack against your opponent's
king
as you guys know the ultimate objective
of the game of chess is to checkmate
your opponent's king
to put him in a situation where the king
is in check
and has no squares so our opponent
was just was just pushing out his pawns
without
controlling the center which is why i
got a very nice position at the start
i'm just developing
and here the move d5 was played now
instead of this what should i have done
what i should have done is try to open
up this file for my rook
sticky bro thank you for the prime how
should i have gone about doing that
can somebody tell me a plan that i can
execute to open up that f file
and don't worry i'll be i'll be pretty
quick here we'll get started on the next
game soon
but you know if you guys are in in here
to improve you want to get better
you know try to engage pay attention ask
any questions you want um no such thing
as a bad question
it's okay to make mistakes i'm we're
here to learn so
i say that every time and i mean it uh d
the sony thing with the prime so knight
d2 would have been correct i did this in
the game
then we pushed the f pawn to f5 and we
take on e6 now why would we want to open
up the f file
let's say that he makes a bunch of
random moves the reason we open up the
f-file
is because it's a direct artery to his
king in fact
white has checkmate in two moves well
technically in three moves here
check on h5 and then checkmate on f7 you
see how quickly
checkmate follows after the king is
opened up like this
um so that's that's a very very typical
situation
okay so instead i played d5
and now i went knight d2 so i did the
same thing in this position to try to
open up that f i appreciate it brett
stick
and and loving the fact that so many
people have stuck around we've got seven
almost 8 000 viewers so uh thank you
guys so much i really really appreciate
it
um okay so i got my knight to a good
square the move
a4 why did i play it i played it to stop
b5
if i'd gone knight c4 immediately he
could have kicked my knight away with
the move b5
okay a4 knight c4 now let me fast
forward
to the moment where i basically almost
ran out of time
so takes rook a4 here i'm just
activating all of my pieces
sacrificing a pawn in order to open up
the center and to get rid of his bishop
and essentially now i thought i was
completely winning but he managed to
survive
so boom boom we got our rook to a great
square
and now the fun starts okay so let's do
this blow by blow
this is called a fork okay not a literal
fork a fork is when a piece attacks two
other pieces
you guys see that the knight the black
knight attacks the queen
and the rook but this is called a pin
it's like a flush and a straight and
poke or a pin is when there is
one piece in another piece and they're
in the same line or diagonal
now one of the pieces that's the piece
that's behind
the pinned piece the pinned piece is the
knight has to be of greater value
so a pin is good because the knight
can't really move if the knight moves he
loses his queen
right that's why this pin is so strong
so it's a fork versus a pin
i moved my queen which means that if he
takes on c4
he drops his queen and a queen is more
valuable than a rook
and i moved my queen to b4 to attack his
knight but now he pushed his pawn out to
d5
all of a sudden this bishop opens up
attacking my queen and he's attacking my
rook
so things get super messy here this is a
discover check
a lot of terminology here but i'll
introduce it bit by bit
the op shot is that this position
occurred on the board this is an amazing
position
because here's the thing i could have
taken his knight on b6
okay that's a free knight or so it seems
now first of all if he takes my rook
what does white do
i just take his queen right if he takes
the queen
then my rook which was being attacked
takes his queen and i'm up a piece
but what did my devilish opponent cook
up here
what does black actually have and i saw
this at the last second i could have
lost this game
this was an amazing idea
watch this who can spot it
who can spot it so rook to you you guys
are is in the right direction
that's exactly the right idea there's a
problem though that
is defended you guys have a good eye for
tactics you're seeing the back rank mate
but here's the thing queen to d5 does
exactly the same thing now the queen
threatens
to checkmate the king no problem right
it's okay
but wait a second the rook is also
hanging so in effect this is a fork
your forking checkmate threat and the
rook white cannot defend both at the
same time
it would be nice if the rook could
travel to e1 but it can't
no matter where you move the rook you
can only block
the check but you can't stave off the
mate
there's nothing i can do if i go rook d3
trying to intercept the queen
then c takes d3 and black will be up a
rook for a bishop which is
a pretty disastrous situation that's
called being up in exchange and so that
is why i played rook to g3 and didn't
take his knight
that's hard to see and kudos to my
opponent for finding this
now i play h3 this is the pin
pawn cannot move because he loses his
king that's illegal
and so i won a pawn and i got a winning
position but at this point i had almost
no time and my opponent continued to
defend very well
now there is one very cool idea i wanted
to show you guys
this is a fork i attack his rook and i
attack his knight
what if he had gone rook to b5 defending
his knight with his rope white actually
has a beautiful
checkmating idea there are several ways
to deliver checkmate but there is one
move that's just
very pretty who can spot it queen to d8
is the fastest mate
but who sees the pretty mate
knows nozzle is on a roll this man and
yep rook hey sacrificing the rook
dropping the king to h8 and queen fate
is checkmate
this is a typical pattern queen delivers
the check bishop holds the king back
right no squares queen d8
also was checkmate this is like the
business approach queen to h8 is made is
also possible
or you could go rook h7 so lots of mates
here
he correctly gave up a piece i traded
queens which is normally what you do
when you're up material you want to
trade pieces
simplify the game and of course here i
had like six seconds
so i had to try my best but what i did
was that i managed to trade rooks
which made the win a lot simpler for me
now i
tossed his king out of the way and won
the pawn and won the game that's
basically what happened
any questions and that was a complicated
game there were some details that i
didn't
that i kind of left out uh but but i try
to sort of give you the thrust of the
game and extract the crucial lessons
great opponent my opponent played very
well and honestly if he didn't play such
a bad opening
uh who knows what would have happened he
gave me a pretty big head start
by pushing his pawns out like this um i
think he played like a 23
2400 or so uh so big big kudos to my
opponent let's go